what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich russell's
just trying to get a lunch money right
and we got a new camera that's right
look at how shiny my forehead is you got
a shiny ass
forehead looking like gold out here
don't worry don't forget that lunch
money's not supposed to have block five
block buy has
three products they buy and sell crypto
on a crypto exchange where you can go do
that with no fees
two is you can deposit crypto and earn
up to eight point six percent apy
in an interest-bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral
go check them out i'm an investor i sit
on the board i'm a happy user and you
will be too if you have a block by
account
and you can get on the wait list for the
new bitcoin rewards credit card where
it's a credit card but you get paid back
in bitcoin rather than cash back go to
blockbuy.com
again blockbuy.com what's up what is up
is
guys there's a lot of scammers in the
comments i try to go in
tell you not to message that whatsapp
number
whenever you see somebody named anthony
pompiano be skeptical it's probably not
him if he's asking for money if he's
asking you to text them
definitely not me i don't want you to
text me i ain't watch your money exactly
so
please don't fall for the scams i am
seeing it every day
um in the second thing scammers are
losers the second thing
um yesterday we talked about how to
properly tie your shoes
well one of our video editors named
jordy
has a third method it's not lupin soup
it's not bunny ears it's some sort of
sorcery i want you to look at this video
i actually haven't seen the video yet
i'll play it for you
and then you can decide in the comments
what kind of what kind of thing this is
ready
play it now okay here we go
so start here
right wait what okay replay
no the people need to see it again slow
mo version he did a slow-mo version
watch it
slow-mo okay here's the same thing but
slower
i i think it's just lupine soup but like
a bougie-ass
version of lucas i don't know what that
just was but i'm pretty convinced that
jordy
is a wizard and knows magic what the
hell was that if anybody can decode this
in the comments please
like one of those movies where there's
like and then bam you're just like
dressed
as a fellow magician i really appreciate
this
it's like bam and then all of a sudden
you're dressed all right
all right next are we ready jordy don't
be showing me any more magic today yeah
let's do it
coin basis financials are now public
ahead of its
stock market listing debut coinbase is
going public we now have
access to its financials uh have you
read the s1
yeah well part of it i haven't finished
the whole thing yet but i've read a lot
of it
1.3 billion in revenue last year they
did about 322 million dollars of profit
and
96 of the revenue comes from the crypto
exchange and apparently it has been
putting crypto assets
including bitcoin on its balance sheet
since
2012. of course they're in the crypto
business
what else are they gonna do wow look
this is a fantastic business
it is run by great operators they are
the number one brand
in the space and they are growing very
quickly
uh i through an spv have financial
exposure to the business
and i am very excited to see what
happens when they go into public markets
fingers crossed that the world accepts
them with open arms and really likes
their business
guys if you make fun of my forehead
today i
will be very upset nobody gonna make fun
of your forehead they gonna make fun of
your five head
no that's why i wear my hair down but
today i i heard you i'm not even gonna
acknowledge you because he be in a bully
okay i mean you got a pretty big five
head there
it's just so shiny damn
all right so you look like a car that
got waxed before i went to the classic
car show
sheesh what you got look at your
forehead
i got a leather forehead i'd be quiet
like i lived life i've been through
things
sarah i think that's how you pronounce
called so rare
wow wow nicholas did you hear that
nicholas did you hear that
sorari sounds much more exotic no so
rare
no it's so rare right it's literally
s-o-r-a-r-e exactly and it's in the
collectible space
it's so rare listen to me a platform
that provides digital soccer
collectibles in collaboration with big
name teams has really just
raised 50 million dollars in series a
funding to grow its community and launch
mobile app
the backers include some pretty serious
names benchmark
excel gary vaynerchuk alexis ohanian
what is benchmark doing in a soccer
collectible sorority
so rare it is incredibly intelligent
in terms of uh what they're building
they basically have created fantasy
football
in the united states but for uh soccer
internationally
and what you have to do is rather than
draft players you have to buy
the nft card and then if you own the
card you can play it in the game
uh so it's a very very interesting way
to do
um kind of sports engagement also to
have a virtual game
and also incorporate uh nfts and
they are growing very quickly uh one of
the founders nicholas and
the rest of the team uh seem to have
really kind of cracked the code on this
so one
i think they're going to continue to
grow but also two is it would not
surprise me somebody goes and builds the
exact same game for fantasy football
here in the united states
uh and kind of really tries to replicate
um
you know the product market fit that
they found goldman sachs
in news what does goldman sachs hate
goldman sachs hates remote work uh
ceo david solomon called it an
aberration
aberration um he said that the firm had
uh basically still managed to have an
average of less than 10 percent of its
staff working in its offices around the
world
he said i do think for a business like
ours which is an innovative
collaborative apprenticeship culture
this is not ideal for us and it's not a
new normal it's in a
aberration that we're gonna correct as
quickly as possible
he wants people back to work butts in
seats
in front of computers in your cubicle
that's all
don't be the monkey sitting in the cage
that's all i must say
if you work at a company where they say
you got to go into an office they don't
even give you the choice
what they're saying is that they don't
trust you but they're saying that they
can't operate with you
remotely they're saying that they can't
actually
allow you the freedom to be a human
humans weren't made to sit in cages
humans weren't made to sit in cubicles
humans were not made to be hunched over
computers all day
stop trying to make them but we were
just talking the other day
how maybe it would be much more valuable
to have a team to work together in
person
because you know give people the option
yeah
say listen there's an office if you want
to go into the office come in we would
love to have you we can work together
if you don't want to come in don't come
in but humans were not made to sit in
cubicles humans were not made to be
hunched over computers all day
stop it stop the madness you know
fanatics
yes okay fanatics china will be a joint
venture with investment from
hill house capital in an asia focused
private equity fund
so uh fanatics uh
is holding off a potential ipo but
it's busy expanding its global
operations in
china fanatics is a fantastic business
i think they will continue their global
domination and when you look at places
like china although i don't like their
human rights record
losers uh i do believe that it has a
massive consumer market
and there will be lots and lots more
sports fans obviously they're really big
with the nba etc
but important we should not chase
profits over holding people accountable
for their human rights record
fair okay next okay so
apparently uh nasa hid a secret
message on a parachute that landed its
perseverance rover down on the surface
of mars
and of course the internet sleuths have
been all
over it they have cracked the code uh
apparently
the the parachute it used for landing
appears to have been secretly inscribed
with the phrase
dare mighty things uh a motto used by
the perseverance team at nasa's jet
propulsion lab
in pasadena california that's really
cool right there mighty things
if you live your life with the with the
uh career title of
internet sleuth we probably need to have
a conversation you would be friends with
the sleuths
such a hard word no i'm friends with the
memers if you make memes on the internet
we're automatically friends like if
you're a good meme
uh dealer we're immediately friends if
you're a lord
meme a meme lord then we're friends if
you're internet sleuth
i don't know kind of sounds like another
name for conspiracy theorists in my book
by the way conspiracy theorists happen
to be right quite often if you guys have
watched the cecil hotel on netflix you
know exactly what he's talking about
okay so we are now on ask lunch funny
time hashtag
ask lm in the comments below in addition
to
what was jordy's sorcery ask your
question all right
daniel j asks favorite clothing brand
i don't know i mean during quarantine
probably lululemon
if i have to i don't know what about you
i don't belong to any tribe i'm an
independent
that's true he never wears why except
nike where all the nike stuff
sometimes you catch me with a little
nike on but that's not a choice it's
just out of necessity because
i needed a pair of shorts now it's the
only fresh pair i had
clean pair what are you wearing today
what's your favorite clothing brand
oh that's not a clothes profile that's a
that is a brand on my shirt okay uh
moist
moist counter day 11. today's day 11
yesterday was day 10 we had an issue
we were reading the day before his
comments exactly so yesterday was day 10
today's day 11. all right
we're on track let's roll yesterday he
said he said day 10 of commenting
uh i am not today but sometimes i do
watch this whilst on the [ __ ]
toilet uh bro mate connections
also i thought about it soul mate like
get it
soul mate s-o-s-o-l-e like the shoe when
you were tying the shoe soul mate
anyway bro mate connections are real and
i feel it too
pump i don't why anyway i thought about
that joke when i was going to sleep last
night i was like i got to bring that up
tomorrow
i he dunks his oreos for three to five
seconds let it drip for a second or two
after i pull it out then i consume
here's a pull
there's no kid that knows anything about
pulling out um
please he said i dunk my oreos for three
to five seconds
let it drip for a second or two after i
pull out then i consume
moist moisture by the way that's the
wrong answer
it's supposed to be five to eight
seconds but we're cool because you wrote
it in a funny way you know how
long five to eight seconds is we're not
trying to have a wet oreo
we're trying to have a soggy oreo a
little bit of soggy in there
come on five to eight seconds everybody
knows the rules voice is not getting a
call from me
but moist i appreciate the answer that
was funny all right i have a new
question
moist important
do you put your socks on or your pants
on first
what kind of psychopath puts their socks
on first
all right well we'll see don't
disappoint
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends